[Music]
did you ever dream that you could meet a
prince charming in real life it finally
became a reality from Snow White in the
Seven Dwarfs too tangled and frozen all
your favorite Disney characters have
been recreated by a talented artist
named you're convinced Jonatan vitamin
do you want to know what they look like
if this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 15 Disney
princes reimagined as real people Flynn
Rider he was the first man Rapunzel ever
saw after spending years alone in a
tower and she couldn't find any
better-looking man but do you know what
makes this character look so handsome he
was designed after a process called hot
man meeting the creators set up a
meeting with all the female employees at
the Disney studio they asked them about
what makes a man good-looking including
the eye color the color of his hair and
his body type this is how they got a lot
of ideas to design the perfect Prince
for Rapunzel now do you want to know
what he would look like in real life we
didn't think that it would be possible
but Flynn Rider looks more handsome than
ever with a pretty face like this we
have to admit that we wouldn't even mind
if the thief tried to steal our hearts
Eric this Prince must have been really
handsome to make a mermaid want to leave
the sea forever with just one look she
was ready to give away her voice and
risk her life for him and you know why
he looked so good Beauty seems to run in
the family in the dining room in Eric's
castle you can see a painting of a man
and a woman who look a lot like Prince
Philip and Princess Aurora from Sleeping
Beauty if these two families are related
we would understand why Prince Eric and
Philip look so good they both have the
best
Jeanne's if you want proof just take a
look at Eric in real life Arielle wanted
to leave the ocean for him and now we
want to leave the real world to meet
this cartoon character if only he were
part of our world this is what a happy
ending would look like Aladdin the
street urchin wanted to use three of his
wishes to make Princess Jasmine fall in
love with him she was not interested in
Prince Ollie but loved him as he was and
so do we
but did you know that Aladdin didn't
always look so good at first he was
supposed to look like Michael J Fox but
the developers didn't think he would
have enough appeal for women Jasmine was
too beautiful compared to him and the
viewers wouldn't believe that she fell
for an ordinary street urchin like him
this is why they made him look older
took off his shirt and designed him so
he would look more like Tom Cruise and
do you want to see what Aladdin looks
like in real life
the genie made our wish come true with
this artwork we can now see a little
more of Tom Cruise in him don't you
think li Shang the captain might not be
a prince but he is a powerful man Mulan
was under his command but not under his
spell that girl had better things to do
than fall for a man until the end of the
film but as viewers we can take the time
to appreciate the look of the one they
call pretty boy and you know what looks
even better Jackie Chan was the actor
who did the voice of the character in
Mandarin he even made a music video of
the song I'll make a man out of you so
li Shang actually already came to life
but do you still want to know what he
looks like reimagined as a real person
here is Lee Sang looking better than
ever if we were a man we wish we would
look like him the Prince this man must
be really handsome to make the fairest
of them all fall in love with him he
barely knew her but
didn't keep him from saving snow-white
with a kiss of true love but did you
know that he was supposed to have a much
more important role in the film he was
supposed to be a part of many other
scenes including one when he is trapped
in a dungeon
and the witch uses magic to entertain
him unfortunately it was too difficult
to animate him convincingly so the
animators were forced to reduce his part
so now we want to see more of this
prince with such a cute look he would be
the perfect match for Snow White
we can't wait for the day this prince
will come Gaston he might not be a
prince but he certainly thought that he
was one this heartbreaker loved to see
that he got a lot of attention from
women but the one he wanted was the girl
who didn't even want to take a look at
him
Belle if only she had taken the time to
do that there is one thing we would know
about him he might still be alive in the
first version of the film you could see
skulls in his eyes when he was falling
but then they were removed so the
viewers would not know what happened to
him so now let's take a look at him
before he hits the ground
Gaston seems happy to have more girls to
flirt with in our world he does look
great but we are just waiting for him to
work more on his personality than his
body Peter Pan this unforgettable
character needs to be a part of our list
as the unofficial Prince of Neverland
but he can't be a king
because this boy never wanted to grow up
so what was the secret to look young
forever the character resembles his
voice actor Bobby Driscoll this child
was only 13 years old at the time and he
already had a role in Song of the South
and Treasure Island this was his last
major role so just like the cartoon
character Driscoll will be remembered as
a child forever now let's take a look at
Peter Pan in the real world he looks
like a young teenager who could be our
highschool crush but we bet that he
won't stay in our world for too long
there are
too many responsibilities out there
kocoum Pocahontas story could have ended
up differently if the princess listened
to her father the young woman was
looking for something more exotic but
that doesn't keep kocoum from being one
of the most handsome men on this land
and actually if a scene hadn't been
deleted we would love him even more the
Native American warrior was supposed to
show his love for Pocahontas as he just
completed their house and talked kindly
to her
he was even supposed to sing to her in
that scene this is much more romantic
than a stranger trying to take away her
land and now let's see what he looks
like as a real person we would love to
see a little smile on his face
but we do like that he looks more
determined than ever
Prince Charming after one night with
Cinderella he already knew that she was
the girl he wanted to marry this is why
he did everything he could to find her
after she ran away we can only dream of
a guy doing all this for us and there
are many other reasons to love Prince
Charming in the movie we were supposed
to see a scene in which he was hunting
to establish him as a sporty type but
then we would realize that he was only
playing with his friend the deer to make
him an animal lover instead we would
have loved to see that version of the
story do you want to know if he looks
better as a cartoon or a real person
let's see how an artist we imagined him
this is a face that we will never forget
even if we saw him just one night do you
prefer this picture or Richard Madden in
the role of the Prince Hercules the
legendary hero was the son of gods with
superhuman strength but that didn't mean
that he could take anything for granted
he had to train hard to be a hero and
then become a god like his parents and
there are probably so many things that
you didn't know about this man the movie
is about Greek myths but the name
Hercules is Roman he would have actual
we been called Heracles in Greek war
over his father is Zeus who is the
brother of Poseidon who has a son named
Triton who has a daughter named Ariel
this makes the two Disney characters
related but now it is time to see how an
artist reimagined him it seems like this
hero is taking a break after fighting so
many monsters
we can't blame Hercules we would be
doing the same thing if we were him
Kristoff he wasn't the kind of guy Anna
would immediately fall for but that is
what made him even better underneath all
these coats was a heart that will love
her no matter what happens
Kristoff was beautiful on the inside and
he was worth the time it took to
discover it but did you know that he was
actually very poor Kristoff didn't seem
to have a home and worked in ice
harvesting which is a dangerous job men
usually do when they really need money
moreover in original draft he was
supposed to help Anna just because of
money but he learned that love is worth
so much more let's see what he looks
like in the real world Kristoff looks
really similar to the cartoon character
we would love to give him a big warm hug
nothing this prince wasn't shy to ask a
random girl to kiss him but novi never
thought that they would both end up
transformed into amphibians we barely
had the chance to know what he looked
like as a human but at first that Prince
wasn't really charming he used to call
Tiana princess and then waitress
symbolizing how he objectified her he
only started calling her by her real
name when he fell in love with her but
since his name means new in Indian this
story is all about change we can forgive
this mistake as long as he behaved well
now now Vigne was transformed into a
frog but now let's turn him into a real
person he'll
so good that we want to see a
live-action movie of this story this
time we wouldn't mind if the prince
asked for a kiss John Smith if a man
tried to steal our land we would be
pissed
so John Smith must have had a little
something special to make Pocahontas
want to teach him about the beauty of
nature what was even better to look at
was the man himself but the real story
of Pocahontas was really different from
what Disney told us the Native American
was only ten years old when she saved
John not in her early 20s so these two
were obviously not in love with each
other
Pocahontas actually married another John
John Rolfe years later in Europe now
let's see what John Smith would look
like in our universe he seems like he is
ready to go on an adventure and we are
ready to follow him who knows where the
wind could take us Philip this Prince
barely got the chance to know Aurora
before she fell into a deep sleep but no
matter what he had the courage to do
everything he could to save her from the
curse and there are many more things
that the princess would have known if
she wasn't sleeping during all this time
we all remember the scene in which
Philip meets Aurora for the first time
but did you know that Disney wanted it
to be so perfect that it had to be done
four times the studio was near
bankruptcy because of that but when we
see the result we think that it was
worth it now it is time to see if this
man looks as handsome as the one we
walked with once upon a dream here he is
we wouldn't mind waking up next to this
pretty face every day Adam we only got
the chance to see the prince at the end
of the movie and it was worth the wait
by learning how to be beautiful on the
inside
Adam learned how to be even more
handsome on the outside if you want to
see what earlier versions of the beasts
character looked like they were actually
part of the movie these drawings were
turned into sculptures in the castle the
supervising animator created him by
combining a lion a buffalo a wild boar a
gorilla a wolf and a bear his blue eyes
are the only things that are human now
is another moment you have been waiting
for the real-life version of Prince Adam
here he is right after the
transformation we would love to run our
fingers through his hair but who do you
think looks better the man in this
picture or Dan Stevens in the role of
the beast and that's it for 15 Disney
princes reimagined as real people which
one would have the chance to be your
prince charming tell us what you think
in the comment section down below and if
you haven't seen it yet don't forget to
watch 10 people who shockingly look like
Disney Princesses thanks for watching
[Music]